hello everyone I'm pleased to announce
my new tour for
2024 beginning in early February and
running through June Tammy and I an
assortment of special guests are going
to visit 51 cities in the US you can
find out more information about this on
my website
jordanbpeterson.com as well as accessing
all relevant ticketing information I'm
going to use the tour to walk through
some of the ideas I've been working on
my forthcoming book out November 2024 we
who wrestle with God I'm looking forward
to this I'm thrilled to be able to do it
again and I'll be pleased to see all of
you again soon
bye-bye you know the deplorables as
Hillary Clinton called them those were
the people that were out on the street
and I would say that they were
everything but deplorables I uh I take
my hat off for you you know I know I
know where my food comes from uh and I'm
very sad that the people in power seem
to have either forgotten it or and this
is obviously the stance that I have
taken know exactly where food comes from
but want to be able to control it in
such a manner that they then also can
exercise control over the general
[Music]
population hello everyone I have the
opportunity today to speak with Ava
vlader Brook and Anthony Lee AA is a
political commentator from the
Netherlands she was integrally involved
in the Dutch farmer protest in recent
years and has recently been with the
German farmers and truckers and Dock
Workers and Railway workers who've
basically brought Germany to its knees
in the last weeks uh even though you may
not have seen much of that in the
so-called Legacy Media C circles anyways
I talked to Ava today and to Anthony
about just exactly what been happening
in Germany and the Netherlands and many
other European countries as well um with
regards to these essentially populist
uprisings similar say to the trucker
Convoy in Canada we discussed the scope
of that movement who was involved um by
group um the aims the consequences and
the likely outcomes on the German and
broader European political front in the
upcoming years and Beyond join for that
so where are you Ava and what are you
doing I'm in Berlin right now in Germany
and I've been uh on the road here in uh
in Germany all over the country for the
past seven days because for the past
seven days the country has witnessed
some of the largest Farmers protest that
Germany has ever seen and um this
protest wasn't actually just joined by
Farmers but was a what I would call
massive uprising of bluecolor workers
ordinary citizens uh people who are just
fed up with the German federal
government people that are fed up
feeling that they have no right to exist
being taxed into Oblivion and just
wanted to make a fist and say we're done
with you guys that was the General
sentiment that I've witnessed around
here uh and uh and I've been reporting
on it I've been going out on the roads
with the farmers cheering them on and uh
and on the first day on Monday last week
I was on the A2 which is the busiest
highway in Europe where I met former
Anthony Lee who is sitting right beside
me who was part of the organization uh
and they conducted one of the largest
roadblocks of the highway there that
well I mean I have ever seen but I think
Germany has ever seen and this was a
roadblock that went on for kilometers
miles and miles on end and I can I can
still get emotional thinking back on it
because it really reminded me of the
Dutch Farmers protest and even the
Canadian um Freedom Convoy at a certain
point we we saw all the tractors going
onto the road because the truckers the
German truckers came to help them block
the road and it was just the most
massive thing that I've seen in a while
and so I met this this hero of a man
who's sitting right next to me uh former
Anthony Lee right there and now we are
in Berlin because today was the grand
finale of the protest of the past week
and uh and he actually spoke today on
stage at the the brbg tour next to the
federal governments to tell the German
government who's boss
essentially so Anthony
why is it that you're involved in this
and I'd like you to speak personally
first like what what is it that has
disrupted your life to the point where
you're willing to use your valuable time
energy and Machinery to engage in
political activity and protest instead
of doing what Farmers usually do which
is like working 16 hours a day so how
long have you been doing this and
exactly what's going on as far as you're
concerned let's let's make it personal
to begin with well yes thank you first
of all for having us on the show it's a
great pleasure um well personally um I'm
just afraid of the future of future for
my kids I have three kids and like um I
think every other Farmer on this world
they want the Next Generation to carry
on doing the job which has uh been going
on through you know dozens of
generations in in some of our cases in
Germany I know friends who are in the 15
16th generation and um now we have a
policy not only now actually I would say
the last 10 15 years we have a policy in
in Germany and uh in all over Europe
actually which is especially um not
Farmers friendly to be uh polite um and
we started in 2019 with round about
15,000 tractors who um came to Berlin to
start this protest and um we've been um
carrying on the last four years uh we
spoke to um politicians on all levels
and um since two years the last two
years we have a I I would say green
dictated government in Germany um which
is making life actually um not only
complicated complicated for us Farmers
or for like if I said the the ordinary
workers the blue color workers uh so um
yeah this is this is why we we um
started uh on the 18th of December last
year with a new massage protest and and
this is this is special now because all
um organizations are united like they've
never been and um we are standing
together uh against this kind of policy
and um like EA said today was one of the
I I'd say it was even bigger than 2019 I
don't have the numbers but I uh I came
to Berlin this morning and I passed I
would say probably 15 20 uh kilometers
long um well um yeah Convoy convoys of
of truck truck drivers um farmers and
this was only from one direction to
Berlin and we came from all over um all
directions and many didn't even make it
into the city because it was packed okay
so there's a bunch of mysteries there to
unpack and the first thing I'd like to
know and that everybody who's watching
and listening needs to know is what
exactly has what green policies in
particular like why do you characterize
the policies as green first and then
what green policies are making your life
as a farmer and Farmers lives in general
untenable and what like why is it having
the impact that it's having provide me
with some details about what it is that
you're facing well um our European
government um the last years I'd say
they came up with uh ideas um of a green
deal they call it a green deal and
everything which which you which you uh
pronounce green is is supposed to be
something good right and and nobody
really has nobody wants to ruin uh the
environment everybody wants to protect
the environment which is good don't get
me wrong but um i' I'd say it's kind of
a agenda um to um get rid of us um like
like um we saw in in Holland the last
two years yes and um we have a thing uh
in Europe in the European Union which is
a part of the green deal they call it
Farm to Fork strategy and there's four
things you have to remember or know
about this strategy 10% of the whole
European Farmland they want um to get
out of use so we not allowed to use
anymore I mean 10% of Europe and which
is kind of quite a a lot um 50% of plant
protection chemical plant protection
they want to cut down 50% I don't know
how they made up this number but it's
it's a hell of a lot it's like if you go
to a doctor and the doctor is only
allowed to use 50% of the medication
it's ridiculous because we need
medication for our plants which is
actually totally normal and then they
want us to have 25% of the European
Union the Farmland only to um used um by
uh organic farming which I don't I don't
have really have a problem with organic
farming but you use the double of space
or land or you only you only Harvest uh
50% if you lucky and um and the this
fourth thing what was the fourth thing
um I think I would mam well I mean what
I think what's important to know is that
just like with the Dutch Farmers protest
we have there is a sort of a structure
to the attack on farming that isn't just
on a national level there's definitely
as you said there's a European green
deal that we're working with which is
pushed forward by unelected bureaucrats
uh in this case for forgive me but a
Dutch man France timmermans who is The
Mastermind or uh the evil mastermind I
would say behind the European green deal
and then in every National country there
is a different set of policies that is
used to Target the specific farming
groups right so in the Netherlands when
we last talked Jordan about the farmers
protest there I told you that it was
about nitrogen right the the cour ruled
in the Netherlands that we are facing a
nitrogen crisis they are using European
legislation for that to get rid of our
farmers and here in Germany what the
mainstream will tell you was the main
reason why the farmers now were
particularly angry or what sparked these
protests was the elimination of tax
breaks on agricultural Diesel and the
backstory to that is that the German
government uh doesn't have their
finances in check and has a huge hole in
their budget and was also trying to fill
that that Gap and they said well let's
go after what they call
clly right suben so climate unfriendly
uh subsidies and so they said we need to
cut back on the tax break that the
farmers get for agricultural diesel
which those taxes normally only involve
like for you know diesel for people who
go out on the road that's what that tax
is for and Farmers obviously just use it
for their on their own land so the fact
that they came after the farmers now and
try to you know Fill Their Own Gap in
their own budget due to their own
mismanagement and they target now the
people that provide us with our daily
meals that initially sparked a lot of
anger but I would say and I think you
would probably agree with me Anthony is
that that there is a a a general
sentiment within the German population
that was very much reflected at these
protests of just feeling like the German
government and not just the German
government also the Dutch government and
European Union is constantly acting
contrary to the interest of ordinary
people who in fact pay their salaries
because they are taxed uh already into
Oblivion right so the the general theme
that we constantly heard there was a a
slogan basically saying the government
needs to go right this wasn't just about
these tax breaks this was really a
general uh dismay great dismay with the
the the federal German government and
the policies that they stand for so Ava
let me ask you about that in more detail
then Anthony I'll go right back to you
um when the protester the truck protest
in Canada emerged there were well there
were all sorts of idiot rumors many of
them spread by the federal government
that this was like a Maga style January
6th Insurrection that it was funded by
Mega Republicans which is about the
stupidest thing I can possibly imagine
or even by Russians but but underneath
that there was a fear you might say as
well as manipulation there was a fear
that this sort of popular Uprising was
anti-democratic in its fundamental
Essence and you know when you say things
like the government has to go I'm
wondering how the two of you reconcile
the fact and you can help me straighten
this out reconcile the fact that Germany
is led by a democratically elected
government and yet these massive
protests are emerging with the
proposition that the government has to
go question is in a democracy what does
it mean that the government has to go
and how do you see what's be what's
happening on the protest front in
Germany acting in a manner that's
commensurate with Democratic principles
Ava maybe you can start that right well
I feel like it couldn't be more
democratic what we are seeing right now
because you are seeing people exercising
their Democratic rights to protest
against a government that doesn't
represent their interest anymore I think
the the general support for the
government has sunk to about 30%
according to the polls here right so
there are people in power right now who
have been in power for the past 2 and a
half years who were elected by the
German people of course democratically
speaking but who have I would say messed
up so majorly that they've lost the
support of the people and that's exactly
the opinion that those people have now
gone out to voice and at their own
expense because I mean like you said
farmers are Hands-On people that
absolutely do not want to spend time
away from their Farms usually because
they simply can't afford it
and the fact that they've now gone out
in such large numbers to protest and
make use of their Democratic rights to
me this is the epitome of democracy and
what you see is that instead of
celebrating that the mainstream media
exactly the way that you described well
the Canadian process they are now saying
well this is an Insurrection these are
people that aren't Democratic this is
extremely far right you know that's the
they constantly St the far right label
on it and especially in Germany in the
historical context of this nation that
label holds a lot of power I mean we all
understand why right so being called far
right is not something that you want in
Germany but it's been overused by the
mainstream media and establishment so
much so that clearly people feel like
well whatever then I'll be labeled far
right but apparently they have nothing
to lose anymore right so it's it's
laughable to me that and but I
understand why they're doing it that
they're trying to label these people
extremist when all what all that I've
seen um are people who are just fed up
with not being heard who actually want
more democratic legitimation to the
government they want to be represented
by the people in power and they feel not
just unwanted and unheard they feel like
they are being threatened in their
existence they are they feel like they
are um ruled by people who essentially
hate them and so that's all I've seen
I've Just Seen ordinary hardworking
people who are are fed up and came to
exercise their Democratic rights Anthony
Ava makes the case that you have to have
a fair bit of gall or desperation in
Germany to Ally yourself with a movement
that's been peled as far right not least
because of the historical precedence of
that terminology for Germany and so I'm
wondering how you regard yourself
politically and and maybe who how you
regard the majority of the people who
are involved in this protest politically
what what set of descriptors do you
think might reasonably be applied to
them and why is it that you decided that
you would overcome the risk associated
with being tarred with the far right
brush to continue the pursuit that to
continue the protest that you have been
engaged
in well I say my personal Advantage is
that I'm half British my my dad was in
the British military so uh I mean I was
born in Germany and raised in Germany
and I went to German school but I'm I'm
I'm I'm not afraid
um of the uh um typical right uh um well
agenda they they are trying to to um
force uh forceed in Germany but many
people still are actually it's getting
less now because um the the the the the
media's overdone it and people don't
really care anymore and you asked about
um the the um our government I mean it's
the new this government's been in charge
for more than two years and uh Germany
um is one of the economic Motors I'd say
the the biggest in in uh in in Europe
and um we are the only the only uh
country uh industry industrially country
which has a they call it a negative
growth in Germany I mean they even try
to make that nice it's ridiculous I mean
how can you have a NE negative growth
and um and it's and it's and they they
they blame it on on Putin on Russia or
on on on on the environment what
whatever you know but it's all housemade
because um this country um is one of the
and was one of the wealthiest countries
uh in Europe and and in the world and um
they managed to ruin our economy in in
uh less than two years I mean they they
switched off the most efficient and and
and safest um nuclear power plants on
the world um and this is all because the
green party in Germany that was their
main gold since the early 80s and and
they managed that and and from from the
day we switched off these um super
efficient uh nuclear power plants we
became
um we have to back for for um for
electricity especially in in France
which is uh mostly nuclear power power
plant in anyway and and you can you can
carry it on with so many things we uh we
are reducing our our best industry in
the world I'd say our car industry you
know they are they are losing they are
losing um what's the right word for it
um contact to the to the to to the
Japanese cars and so on and people see
people see that and people lose money
our inflation rate is the highest in
Europe and it's not going down and it
and you you cannot say it's it's Russia
to blame or anybody else if all the
countries around you hav't having growth
even UK has growth even though uh
everybody said in Germany well now after
brexit they they they will they will um
you know get poor and it's not the case
so people see that and in in even like
AA said in every um every worker has to
pay more and earns less so that's that's
why you know that's why it's turned and
and there's so many people who are who
are fed up of of this government so I've
observed well a variety of things first
of all it's not easy to get coverage of
the Germany of the protests in Germany
on Legacy Media it's as if really
nothing is going on and it's a strange
thing e because watching you guys from
the outside I and I think the same is
probably true of what's happening in
Spain and what's happening in Poland
it's so minimized and invisible that the
only place that I've really been able to
track it is Twitter and so that make it
makes it seem in some real sense that
it's conspiracy teritorial thinking even
to admit to the fact that it's happening
at all so we've outlined but it is
happening and we've outlined some of the
causes and we've noted noted that it's
happening in many countries Canada the
Netherlands Spain Poland Germany and
will continue to do so we've outlined
the fact that there are factors at work
so it's an overarching bureaucratically
imposed topown hypothetically green
agenda that's aiming to make a moral
virtue out of the so-called degrowth
that's indistinguishable from economic
failure and catastrophic guidance and
that's now being touted as a moral
virtue which will do nothing but
impoverish poor people and make them
unbelievably desperate re and reliant on
places like China and India that'll take
the Forefront in the leadership in
Industrial Development and very rapidly
if we don't get IR act together now you
guys have noticed now some evidence for
that I would say for what we're laying
out as the causes can be seen in the
fact that as you guys pointed out it's
not just the farmers in Germany that are
part and parcel of this latest protest
and so Ava can you give us some um
insight into how widespread the
participation has been and what other
groups of primarily working class is my
my U understanding what what other
primary working class groups have become
involved and at what scale right yeah
well so let me paint the picture again
of the of the moment where we met on the
A2 so we actually walked alongside the
Farmers on their tractors on a Dark Side
Road next to the highway where it was
almost you know like a thief in the
night they were trying to make their way
onto the highway which obviously is not
easy to do even in the early hours of
the morning and I thought to myself how
are they going to manage this how are
these tractors going to make their way
onto the highway with all these cars
passing by and then from the corner of
my eye I saw a huge huge Convoy rocking
up of these truckers who all had joined
the protest and made sure that the road
was safe for the farmers to go onto and
that you know that really moved me that
was such a a special moment to witness I
mean my video on Twitter you can hear me
scream you know in joy and excitement
because it was such a true moment of
solidarity from this one group in
society to the other and at the protest
itself we saw I mean yeah the truckers
were there the farmers were there all
sorts of bluecolor workers but also
citizens in their cars who either were
there on purpose because they wanted to
support the farmers or who got stuck in
traffic but who we asked hey do you mind
being stuck here and I I kid you not
like nine out of 10 times they were like
absolutely not I don't mind I know
exactly why these people are protesting
and I agree with them so the the support
was huge and even going around at the
protest looking at the signs that people
were holding you know there's a a nice
word in German mid s of yeah you I guess
you would translate into the the middle
class you know the working class the
class that I would say is being
absolutely obliterated by the globalist
agenda uh under the under the pretext of
this this green you know Green moral
morally
virtuously yeah I mean Utopia that
they're that they're trying to impose on
us which obviously is a a dystopian
world if you look at the consequence
um but so the mitter stun the the middle
class the hardworking ordinary people
that indeed have become increasingly
poor as a result of conscious choices
that were made by an elitist government
a globalist government that do not have
the best interest of the people at heart
and actively work against their interest
I would say that was the the the general
image that I got I felt like we are
witnessing a an uprising of ordinary
hardworking citizens who are being
branded by the mainstream media
unrightfully so as far-right extremists
when in fact all they want is just you
know to be able to exist provide for
their family and do their job without
being crushed by bureaucracy without
being crushed by taxes without being
crushed by derogatory labels you know
the deplorables as Hillary Clinton
called them those were the people that
were out on the street and I would say
that they were everything but deplorable
I uh I take my hat off for you you know
I know I know where my food comes from
uh and I'm very sad that the people in
power seem to have either forgotten it
or and this is obviously the stance that
I have taken know exactly where food
comes from but want to be able to
control it in such a manner that they
then also can exercise control over the
general population and I think that
that's ultimately the goal behind the
climate agenda and using these c um yeah
know the green deal and all of these
ideas as a pretext in order to gain
control over people's lives and and
they're creating crises to do it because
if you uh if you have a population that
is dependent on you for their food uh if
they can't eat you know what is a better
weight than than that than to G to gain
control over
them have you ever heard of data Brokers
they're the middlemen collecting and
selling all those digital Footprints you
leave online they can stitch together
detailed profiles which include your
browsing history online search seches
and location data they then sell your
profile to a company that delivers you a
targeted ad no biggie right well you
might be surprised to learn that these
same data Brokers are also selling your
information to the Department of
Homeland Security and the IRS so to mask
my digital Footprints I protect myself
with expressvpn one of the easiest ways
for Brokers to aggregate data and tie it
back to you is through your device's
unique IP address which also reveals
information about your location when
you're connected to expressvpn your IP
address is hidden that that makes it
much more difficult for data Brokers to
identify who you are expressvpn also
encrypts 100% of network traffic to keep
your data safe from hackers on public
Wi-Fi that's why I have the expressvpn
app downloaded on all of my devices
phone computer and even my home Wi-Fi
router all I do is tap one button to
turn it on and I'm protected it's that
easy make sure your online activity and
data is protected with the best VPN
money can buy secure your online data
today by visiting expressvpn.com Jordan
that's
expressvpn.com Jordan and you can get an
extra 3 months free expressvpn.com
[Music]
Jordan yeah well it seems it seems to me
that it's an easy move for any given
bureaucrat to Proclaim his or her
alliance with the planet with Blessed
Mother Nature to Virtue signal in the in
the direction of a green agenda and to
thereby ratchet him or herself not only
up the moral hierarchy and Pat
themselves on the back but also to use
that as a means of advancing their
career even in micro steps and then you
can imagine that the aggregate
consequence of that across the entire
bureaucratic class able to use this
agenda as a get out of jail free card as
an excuse and explanation for every
failure we're only pursuing degrowth
because of the GRE agenda you can
imagine that all of that Collective
activity going on in the background acts
in a quasi conspiratorial manner to put
this agenda forward and then just so
that we don't assume that I'm only
thinking about quasi conspiracies you
know I've looked very carefully at the
so-called C40 Consortium agenda and this
is a Consortium of the 40 some of the 40
largest cities in in in in on the globe
all Allied together at the level of
local municipal government who are
literally pursuing an agenda that
includes no more than three articles of
clothing per citizen per year a 95%
95% in private car ownership which is
why we're all being uh encouraged to
produce the electric cars that we won't
have enough electricity to run anyways
because you don't need electricity if
you actually don't get to own a car and
if the goal is a 95% reduction in
private automobile ownership then it
doesn't matter if there's no damn grid
one short Hall flight per person every
three years which will completely
obviously decimate the entire travel
industry plus all of the tourism
industry that Europe depends on
absolutely in all possible manners um
and then overall although this isn't
directly from the C40 the uh the
fundamental goal of something
approximating an
85% reduction in Western living
standards which is the calculation of
the green virtuous globalist utopians as
to what's necessary in order for us to
inhabit a a green planet and so all of
this means it's to me it means not only
are the bureaucrats who are using this
get out of jaill free card to Advan
their careers and the conspiratorial
ists who are radically left using it
explicitly as an agenda it also means
that the bloody radical leftists are
100% willing to sacrifice the working
class and the poor to their ambition and
their green agenda now that has
backfired in the Netherlands so let's
concentrate on that for a moment Eva so
the last time we talked it was in the
midst of the farmer protest in the
Netherlands and that produced a genuine
political upheaval now maybe you could
lay out for everybody what happened in
the Netherlands what did situation is
now and what you think that implies for
the future of European political activis
political action in general right well
it what I think we can see for what
happened in the Netherlands was we had
the last major Farmers protests in March
right and then right in March at the end
of March we had general elections in
which the farmer citizens movement and
new a relatively new party got a
landslide Victory and then about a month
ago we had general elections for our
parliament in which the pvv which was
originally branded as the far right
again we can fill Bingo CT with this the
far-right party um won a staggering uh
number of seats for Dutch standards at
least people have to understand we have
a a system in which there are multi-
parties you know we don't have a
two-party system we have plenty and they
always have to form a coalition but this
party the pvv the far-right party won um
about a fourth of all votes and now in
the polls they're even looking at a
third because they're only rising in
popularity and I really think that this
farmers protest and that's why I think
it's so important what you guys are
doing here in Germany and that's why I
wanted to be there is that these the
farmers are in the Vanguard of this
political change it's you guys because
you know anybody with a functioning set
of of eyes and and brain cells no you
know we talk to you we go out in the
streets and if you if you actually see
the people that go out there you see
that those are not extremists those are
normal people and so if you come after
those if you come after the people who
provide you with food that's something
that I think most ordinary people can't
really comprehend it's like why would
you come after the people who provide us
with food that doesn't make any sense
you know and they don't stand for that
so I think that the farmers Uprising in
the Netherlands has had a great impact
on our elections so much so now that
yeah the the the Farr quote unquote has
won and obviously we're not out of the
woods yet because we still have to form
a coalition but it is a major political
shift where I feel like really something
in the hearts and minds of the people
has changed where they're no longer
afraid of the usual intimidation tactics
of the mainstream media uh and and the
establishment they're you know they like
we said they have nothing to lose
anymore do you think Eva do you think
there's a
danger it what might be the danger if
any of normalization of the so-called
farri right agenda I mean there's two
ways of looking at this right because
one way is looking at it the way you
guys have been looking at it which is
that the terminology of far right itself
has been weaponized and now that weapon
is using its losing its potency because
your claim fundamentally is that it's
been applied to the obvious what would
you say to those who are obviously at
the Bedrock of society and that would be
certainly the truckers and the farmers
like
self-evidently and if truckers and
Farmers just going about their business
have become far right then the
terminology itself loses its meaning but
then you could also say well there has
been danger in the past presented by the
far right and the fact that the term no
longer has any validity as a weapon also
means in principle that people who have
a genuinely far right agenda such as
they are can now use this populist
movement to their own advantage to put
forward their hypothetically nefarious
agenda and so I'm wondering Eva how
you've worked through those complexities
in your own mind what you think far
right means now and if you see any
dangers in this populist Uprising let's
say and the transformation of the
political scene that's emerged in
consequence well there are a few things
to say to that I think indeed the one
danger that I could imagine is that
because this term is so overused and has
become so trivialized in that sense it's
like okay if there is a a far-right
subgroup that wants to do all sorts of
evil things then maybe would we wouldn't
take it as seriously anymore because
it's so overused on ordinary people with
valid uh you know totally justified
opinions I don't see them though I don't
see them out on the streets I don't meet
them so what I have personally done in
my own life you know I I've had I've had
my fair share of slander and and the uh
the Dutch mainstream media when I
started out in my political career
called me the shield maiden of the far
right well I was 23 when that happened
to me and I was terrified because I
thought to myself well okay I can forget
a normal life I can forget ever having a
job like Google never forgets so if
somebody Googles you and the first thing
you see about you Shield men of the
farri right well that's not good but
I've now come to the conclusion that you
know there is no point in being afraid
of a label that doesn't actually apply
to you so I just kind of run with it now
it's in my bio on on X because I think
it's funny and I want to show to other
people don't be intimidated by people
who use that label to silence you
because nowadays to me where what I find
is that they put far right on just about
anybody who is somewhat right-wing to
the center who has conservative views
maybe doesn't you know cut their hair uh
short and dyed purple and scream destroy
the patriarchy uh people who oppose
Mass immigration which clearly doesn't
have the best effect on or didn't have
the best effect on Europe and so if you
have those I would say completely
legitimate valid opinions you earn that
title nowadays with the mainstream media
so the best thing you can do is stop
caring because if you stop being afraid
of it then they lose their power over
you and we can demand actual change
which nowadays would be labeled us for
our right but 30 years ago would be just
a Christian democratic deal I've
certainly seen in Canada and and
elsewhere
that everything right now definitely
includes everything that was even 10
years ago regarded as classically
liberal and everything far right
includes everything that 10 years ago
would have been regarded even as
moderately conservative and so and given
that the the radical left actually
occupies only about 7% of the population
and I think that's probably an
overestimate that really means that 93%
of the population have been thrown in by
them by them by the way has been thrown
into the category either of right or far
right now you would think Anthony that
this would be a particularly significant
problem in Germany and so the fact that
ordinary people have chosen to rise up
nonetheless in in spite of being labeled
with these epithets indicates in all
probability that something of dead
seriousness is going on and so what what
is it that you guys who are protesting
want what do you think your protest has
accomplished and where do you think this
is going in the immediate and longer
term future in this rapidly
deindustrializing and failing German
State well the first thing we want is
just uh politicians who have who have
common sense that that that it's it's
very simple and um let me just go back
back one one thing about this green
agenda we have uh in Germany um
everybody's trying to get rid of CO2 um
so CO2 is the the worst thing it will
kill us and we have young people gluing
themselves onto the street especially
here in Berlin um to to uh demonstrate
that we have to cut down on co2
otherwise they call themselves last
generation otherwise we will we will die
you know it's it's so silly that and and
and the media is honestly um they
cutting down a bit on it now but but
it's still onto it and this is the main
agenda especially to us Farmers um
because we have to cut down on co2 and
that's why this green deal these four
things I told you about and and
especially the main reason what IFA just
described to tax our Diesel and and um I
I only live about 150 km away from from
Holland in Holland or in Belgium or in
France they don't tax diesel at all so
um it's an unfair uh thing for us in in
Europe to compare we can't compete
obviously not and um and anybody should
know that we in Germany our farmers use
one liter diesel so efficient like
nobody else can do it on this planet
yeah so obviously if we don't if we
don't produce the food we will have to
get it from somewhere else and we have
we had some um a very good um uh passage
last year in in a in a Austrian
newspaper and they said the green deal
from the European Union is a bad deal
for the planet because if we do these
things that I told you a few minutes ago
we will have to um we need 8 million
hectares somewhere else on the World to
feed us which will mean we use we have
to use big ships um to to get the food
to us to Germany which is bad for the
environment because we will pollute the
air with CO2 which will kill us and we
will take poor people food away and and
anybody who says especially from the
green party who said well it's a good
idea to do the green deal he should
reflect himself and think no it can't be
it's
absolutely contrary to that sense or
that that that meaning we want to do you
to to protect the planet to get rid of
CO2 you're doing the opposite by far and
people more and more realize this
nonsense we're doing and um they fed up
of it because it's costing us money it's
C costing us uh our economy like I told
you and I mean it's the same we we we um
we cut down uh I mean we we we got a lot
of gas from Russia until the Ukraine war
and it was quite quite quite cheap for
us which was good for our economy so we
cut down we said well we not we don't
want it anymore by the way let me
explain this so anybody from outside um
Germany realized this Spain for example
which is a member of the European Union
Imports double the size of gas from
Russia than before the Ukraine war so
which is silly because I mean we all
have the same rights in the European
Union but we and our government says no
we don't want it because we don't want
to give Putin uh money and so even
though I live in a state which called is
called Lower Saxony it's in the middle
of Germany we have um gas um we could
Frack is it fracking we could Frack
fracking yeah we could Frack um gas for
30 years for the German economy we don't
want to do it because it's bad for the
environment we rather yeah buy it from
the US or from uh the Middle East and
pay five times as it's much and we are
dependent on um governments from um the
Middle East or from America from the
United States and then we have to we
have to uh import it it's so silly which
is obviously bad for the environment but
they say it's green you know it's it's
so it's I mean we are doing the exact
thing you're doing the exact thing and
it so well so so so are we in Canada so
Quebec the province of Quebec in Canada
has enough natural gas in Quebec to
supply all of Quebec for 200 years or
the EU for 50 and they refuse to Frack
any of it because fracking is so
dangerous and by the way I grew up in
Northern Alberta and they had fracked
there for like six decades with no
problem whatsoever and so I know all of
that is absolute bloody nonsense but the
the advantages of this green virtu in
virtu signaling at the local
bureaucratic level are so astounding
that all of this idiocy can pass by as
green legislation even though it flies
in the face of both common sense and
fact so I know for a fact for example
that not only is Germany electricity in
Germany something approximating five
times as expensive as it should be which
given the dependence of industry and
everything else all of Commerce on cheap
energy is a bloody catastrophe I know as
well that you guys are producing more
carbon dioxide and more waste per unit
of energy than you were 10 years ago
because you shut down the bloody nuclear
plants and have substituted instead
liite burning coal plants which is like
utterly insane so just so that everybody
watching and listening is clear here not
only are these green policies
devastating to the working class and to
the poor and to the economic stability
of Europe as as a whole and then to the
stability of the world in general they
are counterproductive by the standards
put forward by the green Advocates
themselves in that as you pointed out
well first of all you have to import
your bloody power at a tremendously high
cost and then you're going to shut down
local production of food in favor of
imports and it was only a few years ago
that all the green revolutionaries were
jumping up and down screening screaming
about the fact that you should buy local
exactly to decrease the kind of
Transportation costs that you're
pointing to and
so it's such a mystery a because the
policies that are being pursued don't
even suffice to service the goals that
are hypothetically trumpeted by the
formulators of the policies themselves
it's a bloody miracle miracle of
stupidity and blindness I've given this
so much thought because so many people
have asked me why you know why would
they do this it doesn't make sense
explain it you know why would you come
after the most hardworking sector the
most lucrative sector the the the people
that provide you with food why would you
shut down your nuclear plants if you are
to import electricity for I don't know
how much more the price why why why and
uh I think it was Carl Yung actually who
said if you can't understand someone's
actions you have to look at the
consequences and infer the motive and
that's what I've done with all of this
if the consequences of the of their
policies are that we become poorer and
you know we not they obviously but we uh
if we become poorer uh we become more
dependent on them we uh you know we
basically essentially would starve if
this is put through and we don't have
the financial means anymore to import
our food and uh well I don't know God
forbid the disaster happens we've
outsourced everything you know we could
be in real trouble well if those are the
consequences then apparently that's the
motive i' I maybe I've become too cic
iCal but I find it very difficult to um
to explain it any other way because this
is not a one-time mistake you know these
people are the Net Zero scam and I would
really call it a scam is is something
that it's a criminal scam yes criminal
scam it's not just a scam it is crim it
is Criminal and I think that it is of
the worst type of Injustice if a
government and the people are supposed
to represent us you know talking about
democracy liberal democracy and all if
those people turn their backs on their
own population and not just turn their
backs but actively again go against
their interest and and and allow them
essentially if things go wrong to become
poor and to starve and I can't see you
know I see true I see true evil Behind
these acts I don't just see incompetence
anymore it's worse than that AA it's
worse than that even because I was
speaking with someone the other day one
of my podcast guests who said that their
sampling has indicated that young people
now now think about climate apocalypse
three or four times a day right they're
literally obsessed by it and we know
perfectly well that that demoralizing
insistence that all human striving is
planet destroying you know patriarchal
ambition and has to be brought to a halt
not only does it risk economic
catastrophe um really right down to the
fundamental level in the way that we've
been describing but it's also
demoralized an entire generation of
people and made them afraid terrified
like chicken that the SK sky is falling
even when the ipcc itself who who are
hypothetically the people that you know
are on top of the appropriate data have
indicated nowhere in their documentation
that we're facing anything approximating
a true emergency and so well and so that
does beg the question as you said you
know just exactly what the hell is going
on and I think that your method of
inferring the motivation is is actually
the case I think the
proximal cause is the the fact that just
as in Nazi Germany let's say that any
old midlevel bureaucrat could ratchet
himself up the hierarchy by identifying
at least in principle with the
overarching Nazi ideology it's
absolutely the case with these
bureaucrats who bear no immediate
economic consequences for the idiocy of
their actions if they put forward this
green agenda and they're celebrated by
the radiate peers for doing so that's
definitely good in the immediate present
for their Career Development and their
you know their self
aggrandizing moral proclamations of of
of virtuous self and in the aggregate we
get exactly this sort of thing Anthony
what consequences do you think that
these protests are going to have practic
have had let's start with that what
consequences have they had and what do
you think is going to unfold because
this is a relatively new government in
Germany and it isn't obvious to me that
it's going to fall apart in consequence
as the government in the Netherlands did
certainly the Canadian government sailed
right through the trucker protest as if
it never even happened and the
probability that Justin Trudeau is going
to rule with his velvet fist for the
next year appears to be extremely high
so what do you think's going to happen
in Germany as a consequence of these
protests well it's very hard to predict
um the government didn't learn its
lesson yet that's that's obvious we had
our finance minister
on stage today and it was obvious he
didn't learn anything about our uh
actions we did but uh the what what we
what we already achieved is that we are
like I said in the beginning so United
like I honest honestly never thought we
could be if I said that I mean I would
say 80% and this is this is is an
official poll of our mainstream media
80% says they they are behind our
actions behind our it's not a strike
it's a protest
and um that's amazing that's honestly
amazing especially um getting um in
front of this agenda what we were
talking about and like I said people are
realizing that now and they're realizing
it for one reason they believed
everything or most of them believed all
this agenda we have to save CO2 to save
our lives and all that nonsense but now
it's costing them money everybody's
paying for this and we are paying a big
price and we didn't talk about uh even I
mean with the war in in in Ukraine um
obviously Ukraine um produces a hell of
a lot of Wheat and crop for the for the
poorest in the world and if you if you
look into where the wheat um if it gets
out of the Black Sea region goes to it
mainly goes to European countries turkey
and China it doesn't really go to Africa
where it should where it should go and
it comes to us um Poland Hungaria they
said said we don't want it they shut
their borders so it's coming straight
through to Germany and um the Danish
government only recently um checked uh
if it's if it's contaminated with uh um
chemical um chemicals which are not
allowed in in the European Union and
they said yes it is it's Al so it's
official but nobody cares so we are um
not getting the price we should get for
our crop our grains and we we we are
getting over overflown by um rain from
the Ukraine which which isad which is
really bad I mean obviously it's bad you
know first of all poor countries aren't
getting it we can't get rid of ours and
um the government's even paying uh some
parts of the transport to Germany so
they are obviously pay using our tax
money to um to make sure we get a bad
price for our for our crop well I think
we were already talking about how
demoralizing this agenda is and food of
course if you want to demoralize a
people I mean it's done by feeding them
bad food as well I mean Jordan you know
I don't have to tell you about this but
the importance of of good meat of
healthy animal
fats it's it's huge and if you make
people feel like the only thing that
they deserve is you know bad bad meat or
bugs insects or synthetic meat you know
feed literally food that will make you
weak uh I think that says something
about our establishment you know it says
something about the way that we are
governed it says something about the way
that we are ruled that we are supposed
to live as if we are livestock that you
know it can only eat insects or or
basically you know trash and and and who
produce carbon dioxide simply by
breathing let's say m and produce
children and produce children who are a
net birden on the ecosphere etc etc and
and want to travel and want to buy
things and want to have a standard of
living want to
have absolutely absolutely absolutely
when when everything you do does nothing
but muck up the planet and Mar the
future yeah it is an absolutely bloody
dismal view of humanity that's for sure
and bordering on murderous yeah it's
it's malthusian to say to least and I
mean you know we're King about we're
joking now but there was an actual
headline not too long ago in the here in
the UK and in Europe quoting a study
that said that breathing causes climate
change well you know what's the
consequence of that then do you want me
to stop breathing that's the only that's
the only answer to the problem then
right so it's yes it's absolute content
so you know the the the the the human
progress people have documented the fact
that every baby born will produce seven
times the economic resources that every
baby consumes and so the idea that's the
historical average at the moment the
idea that more people means more poverty
and more environmental degradation is
not only a lie it's an anti-truth and
here's another so not only so imagine
first of all if every baby consumed more
than It produced then than people on
average would starve and on average a
far smaller proportion of people are
starving than has ever been the case in
the entire history of the planet we're
going to Peak out at about 9 billion and
it's Crystal bloody clear that we manage
that and then there's going to be a
precipitous decline that's the
demographic Outlook and that's within
this Century then here's some so the
idea that each person born con produces
less than they consume is a complete
bloody lie it's out by a factor of seven
and then here's the Here's the Clincher
this is so this is so staggering the the
best data indicates quite clearly that
if you can get poor people so absolutely
poor people not relatively poor people
so people in danger of food privation
let's say and lacking opportunity for
their children if you can get them up to
a point where they are producing $5,000
US GDP per year they immediately start
to take a medium and long-term view of
let's say environmental stability and
sustainability because they have enough
wherewithal and enough resources at
their disposal so that they don't have
to be in a per in the permanent state of
Crisis that incentivizes them to burn up
and consume every around them so the
best data indicates very very clearly
that if we drove Energy prices down or
allowed them to decline as we could if
we used intelligent nuclear technology
for example we could raise the planetary
standard of living to the point where
everybody locally would start to become
concerned about environmental issues and
Act Naturally in a manner that would
provide for a more sustainable World
instead we're doing the opposite to
Virtue signal stupidly we're cranking
Energy prices up claiming that all the
industri activity has to cease making
poor people even poor and putting them
at risk of of starvation all that's
going to do as it's already started to
do in Germany is make both the economy
and the environment worse and it's going
to breed while more and more uprising of
the sort that we're seeing everywhere
you you couldn't imagine a more
counterproductive agenda and to say it
again counterproductive even by the
standards of the people who are
hypothetically putting the agenda
forward it's like why they hell would
you oppose nuclear power that's utterly
insane especially in a place like
Germany especially when you Germans then
have to import nuclear power from the
Scandinavians and the French you know
it's it's so blind that it's a miracle
but it's it it baffles me already that
we live in a Time apparently where we
have to justify our existence with data
you know that's that's something that
deeply bothers me it deeply bothers me
no kidding yeah no Kidd I mean and you
know uh this will of course lend me
another label in uh in in in secular
Europe but I think that the death of God
that you so often discuss as well is is
ultimately the the main reason for that
you know if you forget that people have
intrinsic value because they are created
in the image of God and they're just a
number and if we have to work to Net
Zero and we need to now see if you add
something or take too much and you have
to justify your own existence by quoting
scientific studies I think we've gone
off the Road man like and bad time like
this are we we are are we China now is
that is that what we are these these
people have their mouths full constantly
they're always talking about human
rights here and there but now we have
come to a point where we have to justify
our entire existence to our meian
overlords and I'm not okay with it yeah
I'm not okay with it yeah I'm not okay
I'm not okay with it either and the
whole malthusian the whole malthusian
proposition so let's just walk through
that a second so that's a biological
metaphor so so let's just walk through
that a minute just to show exactly how
wrong it is okay so now there's lots of
situations in which the use of
biological metaphors Can Shed light on
human nature and even the nature of
human what would you say striving and
thriving so psychologists use Mouse
models all the time and that's partly
because the neurochemistry of a mouse
brain for example it's very similar to
the neurochemistry of a human brain
there's all sorts of analoges in
behavior and function that are relevant
but the malthusian doctrine is based on
a very lowlevel analogy so the analogy
is essentially this if you put a
microorganism in a Petri dish so it has
enough um agar enough food substrate so
that can Thrive it will multiply to the
point where and rapidly geometrically or
exponentially to the point where it
consumes all of its resources and then
it will catastrophically
collapse okay and so and you can see
that same thing occurring in some
natural populations if you provide a
natural population with no predation and
a plethora of resources in a constrained
environment then it the or population
will grow until it consumes all the
envir resources and collapse okay so why
aren't
people microorganisms in a Petri dish
well there are some constraints on what
we can produce and consume like there's
different what would you say uh scarcity
of different fundamental elements for
example such that some things will
always be more expensive than others or
almost others almost always there's some
natural scarcity but here's the
fundamental difference between human
beings and other
creatures
so we can
produce we can innovate and we can
produce variants of ourselves that can
die instead of us so on the Innovation
front The Innovation front and these
things are tied together because we can
think because we can transform
cognitively we don't have to die or vary
genetically we can transform cognitively
that's our Niche and the fact that we
can transform cognitively means that we
can make constant scarcity into variable
plenitude and we've done that constantly
things we regard As Natural Resources
hydrocarbons for example oil gas those
things were of zero value in 1820 zero
they weren't natural resources at all it
wasn't until we figured out how to use
them how to substitute them for whale
oil for example that they became this
unbelievable source of wealth that was
immediately available everywhere it was
a cognitive transformation and
Revolution and there's no end to the
degree to which we can use that
cognitive Revolution to increase
plenitude and that's exactly why for
example that every baby born today will
produce seven times as much as they
consume now you might say at some scale
there's going to be some limit to
plenitude but it isn't obvious at all
that what that's going to be and it
certainly isn't obvious that we've
reached that limit and that's especially
true when you consider the possibility
of computation because we're in this
situation now where our Computing
resources which take up you know
comparatively little resources and
energy are multiplying at a rate that's
absolutely Beyond Comprehension and we
have no idea how much we're going to in
10 years so the malthusian notion there
isn't anything about the malthusian
notion that's correct except for yeast
and bacteria and you know if you're
going to treat people like yeast and
bacteria then we're going to be in the
same damn situation that we're in now
right where we have to justify our
existence by data because the world is
full of scarcity and maybe the only the
elites who have our best interests in
mind are going to be allowed to thrive
yeah yeah I think I can think of a
far-right ideology that talked about
people as being dirty you know and uh
and and bacteria and now we are dealing
with a a left-wing ideology that is
doing the exact same thing and making us
justify uh our existence and yet they
call the people who opposed to it far
right so we're full circle yeah yeah
well I saw recently that uh Trudeau's
minions are now um what would you say
working behind the scenes to ensure that
the Public Health officials at the World
Health Organization who are so concerned
with the control of the next pandemic
just like they were with the last one
are also now moving to ensure that
climate catastrophe will be included
within the P domain of Public Health
concern that the you know Global
overlords are going to be able to yes
going to be able to manage and your your
comment about you know farri
totalitarian governments treating people
as if they're infectious agents right
cancers on the planet let's say we know
perfectly well again from the data that
that drives a totalitarian agenda as
soon as you use language of
contamination pollution and disgust to
characterize someone let's say human
beings you immediately elicit the
unconscious and conscious activations of
the disgust systems that protect us from
contamination and those are very
dangerous once they're activated they at
destruction right at the destruction of
the pathogen yes and those people those
are the ones that the farmers the
truckers the people that we've seen out
on the streets today have protested
against that's why they were out on the
street and when I said that earlier in
this conversation we are we have been
speaking to people who feel like they
are ruled by people who hate them and
that's maybe they can't voice exactly
why you know they can come up with
examples obviously they are feeling it
in in their own finances they but they
can tell and I think that people
ultimately on a on a human level on a on
a soul level can feel when they are
being despised by others and this
exactly this notion that you are just
describing right now Jordan that I think
is the motor behind this protest people
can sense that they are being hated
people can sense that they are being
despised and they are done with it
because they realize that they are the
ones paying for it and that the state
should be here to serve us not the other
way around Anthony just out of curiosity
you know you you you and Ava have just
talked about the the the breadth and
depth of this protest and its positive
effects but you closed by pointing out
for example that the Finance Minister
that you guys talked to or that spoke to
you right at the close of the protests
doesn't have seem to seem to have
learned a damn thing which doesn't
surprise me in the least and so that
makes me question just how effective
what you've done so far is and I want
your opinions about that and then I'm
also curious like why didn't your now
United organization given your 80% um
level of public support call for
something approximating a general strike
and just bring the whole bloody thing to
a halt yeah but that that would be the
obvious thing but um our um well what
explain it um well actually it's against
the law to do this general strike um
because we we it is it obviously is
against the law but I I reckon we have
to come to the stage where uh we have to
break the law sometimes which is not
meaning violence it's like just Civil
Disobedience yeah exactly yeah that
that's that's probably the next stage
but um we have to talk about that um
between us between between the
organizations but you you're completely
right
um I mean we gave the government two
options or there there are two options
either
they they they turn back to a policy
which is which is for the people like if
I said which is definitely not I mean we
forgot loads of things which which are
going completely wrong in Germany I mean
we have we have a a farming Minister
who's telling us we should only eat and
this is this is not a joke 10 grams meat
per day right this is honestly what they
are trying to tell us 10 grams yeah
right which is which is nothing yeah
when the politicians start telling you
what you can and can't eat it we've
crossed a line it's like you don't get
to tell me where I set my thermostat you
don't get to tell me what I can drive
and win and you certainly bloody well
don't get to tell me what I can eat like
fundamentally and seriously to hell with
you and what it also indicates to me and
and increasingly clearly is that once
you're waving the flag of planetary
savior on the environmentalist front
once you've turned 100% to that kind of
nature worship there is absolutely no
level of control whatsoever that you
won't stoop to and justify by your moral
pretention right redounding to your
credit and increasing your power at the
same time as it does so all right so
they're perfect so this this begs the
question though doesn't it like I
watched Claudine gay resign from Harvard
and I've watched the moderate left wiers
flop about now in in increasing
consternation recognizing as they do the
absolute danger of the diversity equity
and inclusivity idiocy that's part and
parcel of this what would you say
radical leftist line of anti-human
thinking but at the same time I see that
I don't believe that Harvard as an
institution has learned a damn thing and
I don't believe that the moderates on
the Democrat side in the United States
for example have any idea what soever
How Deep The ideological corruption and
rot has become and so you've pushed
forward this protest but as you said
yourself you still have members of the
government firmly in charge you think
that we should eat 10 grams of me today
and who don't believe that they're going
to throw you a bone or two maybe in the
near future but the probability that
they're going to revisit the ideology
upon which they've based their political
Empire Strikes me to be close to zero so
again you said the future's uncertain
and unpredictable what do you think's
going to happen and what should happen
uh we have three um elections this year
in East Germany and East Germany um U
the polls show that the far right party
the afd in Germany is um by far in in in
the lead in these polls and which will
which will um be like an earthquake in
our politician in Germany because we
never had this situation
and if this happens and and I reckon it
will because like you said they will not
change their policy um things will
change rapidly in Germany because like
you know politicians uh they they want
power and to get power you have to
compromise and I and and even though
they now they now say we we're never
compromised we never go together with
this party I reckon just because they
want what they want the power they will
and that will be a landslide it will be
completely change Germany um but that
would saying that that might even still
um I still have
hope I if hope is the right word that
our actual government will change the
way um they they govern not by 180°
which which we need but maybe a few
degrees um but and and that might these
two options are on the table and only
these two options okay well something
okay well something similar to that has
happened in the Netherlands so now Ava
what's the status of the government in
in the Netherlands and is G wers going
to head up the new government is that
how it looks and what do you think of
him and and what do you think again
let's talk about this a little bit what
do you think the dangers are that
present themselves in consequence of
that in the Netherlands the same thing
applies to Germany and we could also
talk about the afd to some degree
because they're certainly pillared as
far right in Western media certainly in
North America you know they're viewed as
to right of Victor Orban I would say and
he's definitely Persona nonr to the
Legacy Media so let's start with the
situation again in Netherlands and then
move to what you see Ava as being most
likely um in Germany I'd like to hear
your thoughts about the afd as well okay
so we are still in the process of
forming a coalition right now as I said
we have a very scattered political
landscape and so all of the parties that
one will need to form or have
negotiations and form ultimately a
coalition to have a majority in
Parliament so without that it's going to
be difficult to pass any legislation
obviously so this process is very
important what is now happening is that
the let's just say the the Legacy
parties The Establishment parties that
we've that have ruled the Netherlands
and I would say destroyed it actively
for the past 30 years are doing
everything in their power to stall that
process because her Builders is becoming
increasingly popular as I said he got
one out of four votes in the elections
just a month ago and now he's pulling at
one in three votes so the last thing
that they want right now is the
Coalition formation Pro process to fail
and for new general elections to be
called because then he's going to become
even bigger so what I think the
political strategy at home is is they're
going to stall that process for as long
as possible the parties the moderate
right-wing party the Centrist parties
they're going to protect tends to be
willing to work with him and then
they're going to drag it out so long and
they're going to say at a certain point
well you know this man is just
impossible and they're already saying
that he has said things that go against
the Constitution and that are a threat
to the rule of law Etc so they're
building their case and I think that
that is something that we see everywhere
is that this you know this is a war of
attrition essentially so we have to be
prepared for all of these games however
I think something similar might happen
in Germany but what I do think is that
the genie is out of the bottle with the
people and that to me is ultimately the
only thing that matters I don't put any
of my solace in the political party
system anyway what I do care about is
the willingness of people to stand up
for what they believe is right and to
not be intimidated by people who lie
about them and about what they stand for
right so what I think is going to happen
in Germany with afd the people that I
have met from afd what I've seen about
afd is they are are conservative people
who essentially are saying well the idea
Merle's idea to let 1.2 million migrants
in in one year in 2015 might have not
been the greatest idea you know to me
that's a very legitimate standpoint
extraordinarily legitimate especially
because there is no alternative no pun
intendent in Germany really asides from
prise from the parties that have
destroyed the country very actively so I
think that they are going to win by a
much larger margin than the poll suggest
right now just like what happened for us
cuz the pvv was also not you know they
weren't pulled at the the extent that
they now have won the elections with um
and I think that that will change
something in the mindset of the Germans
because like I said if if even in
Germany that label doesn't hold enough
power anymore to deter people from
voting for change then you really know
that the government is messed up right
you really know the establishment has
messed up and that the people are fed up
so I personally I think that Germans who
want change have no choice really but to
vote for the right-wing parties and I
would say say essentially not for any
party that has governed the nation in
the last 10 years okay so do you see and
and and and I I'd like both your
opinions on this it's so difficult to
get a handle on any of this say because
you know I've been watching the
political landscape for a very long time
and certainly the the the um the idea of
KT Builders has raised my hackles in the
past and I would say that's because I'm
profoundly at least because I'm
relatively ignorant about politics in
the Netherlands and and still
susceptible to the consensus view
developed by the low resolution pictures
presented by the Legacy Media and so I
don't know what to make of that and
exactly the same thing applies to the
afd um and so I'd like to know from both
of you what dangers if any you think
this tilt towards this more we've
already taken apart the notion of the
right God Only Knows even what that is
anymore given the overuse of the term
but do either of you have any qualms
about these political
Transformations do you think that they
could just because you're fighting
something that in and of itself is
reprehensible and destructive doesn't
mean that the weapons that you use to
fight it can't also po precisely the
same danger so Ava maybe you could start
by commenting on that especially with
regards to the afd and then Anthony you
could chime in with regard to Germany
well I mean these are the both the
upsides and the downsides of democracy
in general that we're discussing I think
so of course the the instrument or the
alternative can also turn bad but then
that's inherent to democracy and the
fact that we have to form coalitions in
our Democrat systems at least that's
somewhat of a safeguard in a sense that
they are going to have to work together
with other parties anyway so let's say
God forbid that these parties turn out
to have crazy ideas that we absolutely
didn't want and didn't vote for we have
to either trust in the fact that the
system will correct it or I think you
can throw away the entire concept of
democracy almost all together right so
the I think that a lot of people here
are trying to use the the possibility of
maybe IFD going too far in certain
aspects or you know not having I hear
another argument often that they say oh
well they don't have good people they
don't have enough uh people with with
enough qualities to govern the country
I'm like well I don't know if the people
who are in power right now do like
clearly you know you guys have a bit of
an issue on your hand so you might as
well try and I think that that is
essentially what this country needs you
know something needs to happen and like
I said I'm not one to put all of my
Solace and trust and hope in the
political system anyway but it is very
clear to me that Germany and Europe in
general is on a path of National Suicide
so might as well try something else for
once and I you know because I find
myself in the position so often that
I've been called far right for what I
think are perfectly valid opinions that
I I I care a little bit less at this
point you know I'm like no I think we I
think something just needs to change
here and I try to trust in the
democratic system and that it will cor
itself that terrifying Spectre Maloney
in Italy who everyone and Sundry was
warned about in no uncertain terms
forever you know tantamount to musini
and her fascist proclivities has turned
out to be a hell of a lot more moderate
even than the people who voted for her
might have hoped so these specters of
fascism that keep looming turn out to
have a lot less teeth than feared when
they end up what would you say when they
end up acquiring a certain degree of
political power now you know Orban has
been the most
successful conservative figure in some
ways in on the European scene and he's
still demonized roundly and continually
in the western media but it's also been
my apprehension with regard to Hungary
that things are nowhere near as dismal
there as they might have been given all
the fear that was engendered around
orban's policies and so what do you what
do you think about that and then Anthony
will turn to your feelings about the afd
in Germany yeah I think I think you're
very right I mean when I go to to to
Hungary for example personally and when
I speak to other people who go there a
lot of people feel like they can finally
take a breather it's like oh that's nice
you know this is what Europe used to be
like 50 years ago 30 years ago in some
countries even less and and I am a upset
as a
27-year-old that I have never
experienced Europe as safe as
functioning as sane normal dare I say
you know as I find a city like budapes
to be you know my my
parents had that experience my
grandfather sure as heck had that
experience but I never had it and I
never voted for it you know I have
always growing up had to be afraid going
out after dark you know
it's it's just that's that's our our our
reality right now and that's our reality
not because it happened like a natural
disaster but because people in power
made the wrong decisions actively and I
think that everybody can agree to the
fact that a country like Hungary is not
you know the dictatorship that they make
it out to be in the media the what I saw
the time especially the last time I was
in Budapest I was there for a symposium
on on promo of the family which seemed
to be you know relatively positive um
and certainly a non- malthusian concern
I mean if you if you're in the airports
in Budapest for example what you see are
plethora of posters celebrating the
family as the core Bedrock social
institution of the polity and that just
doesn't strike me as particularly Nazi
in its derivation especially and so this
and I know the president of Hungary to
some degree and she's a woman who is
quite admirable in my estimation who
spent most of her career trying to
figure out how to protect the family and
how to economically incentivize the role
that women play in reproduction in
keeping with opening up the
opportunities for them on the economic
front in general and is produce policies
that have decreased abortion
substantially without Force decrease
divorce increased the marriage rate and
also increased the rate at which women
are particip participating in the
broader General economy and so none of
that particularly screams fascism to me
and and the fact too that we've seen
well the that the the the consequences
of the election of baloney and also what
of the so-called farri parties in Sweden
seems to me to indicate that there's a
lot
more fear there than is justified by the
by the consequences especially in
contrast to this absolutely insane
utopian self-serving moralizing green
agenda that provides an absolute excuse
for everything you can possibly
conceptualize Anthony in terms of the
afd how do you think it is being
perceived by the protesting class now
the people that you've been talking to
the truckers the farmers the the people
who work for the railways The Dock
Workers cuz they were all involved in
this protest as well and what dangers do
you as a German citizen see on the
fascist side so to speak as a
consequence of these populist movements
well uh me myself I'm I'm in politics uh
for the last eight years and I was in
the CDU that that was a party from
Angela Merkel and um um I left the party
about a year ago and I moved to uh the
party is called firea I would say they
are the old CDU as I knew it 20 years
ago and um the afd yes it's a far right
party which is which is is is gaining on
popularity um massively and the main
reason is I think is the same reason
like uh in Italy and in Sweden migration
we have a we have a massive migration
problem in Germany we have uh I say
right about 5 to six million people
since 2015 who came to Germany and at
the moment we are we are uh way over
300,000 this year and it's it's it's not
the problem with migration the problem
is who is coming and we don't even know
who is coming up till 2010 I was police
I was a police officer in Berlin we had
a massive problem with migrants in them
days because the migrants who come now
are mainly young men from uh Muslim
countries and like I said we don't even
know who is coming because they come in
they they are they allowed to stay here
even though it's against the law and we
don't obey the law the government
doesn't obey the law like it like it
should be and um governments like Sweden
I mean Sweden is very
liberal as I know it I mean even they
change even Denmark you didn't mention
Denmark because Denmark isn't governed
by a right-wing party but they are
governed by a female um president who is
Social Democrat but what what she what
she did is she uh she uh uses the same
methods the politics the right-wing
party uh kind of is and um and that's
that's why the right-wing parties in
Denmark aren't existent anymore to be
honest so it's not who who who runs a
country which which which part which
well which which right or left wing it's
what policy do you do in your country
and and and talking about the afd um
it's very very strong in East Germany um
because the East Germans I think they
have we say they better antennas um
which you know what I mean because they
I mean they come from a from the DDR so
they the Elder people who who lived in a
in a in a climate like they did they
know if something's not going right in
in your country and that's why they they
turn to the afd more than than we in the
west do and and it's not and and many
say they should be forbidden the party
should be forbidden and and I I say who
Am who are we the people to say it's not
uh it should be forbidden or it's not a
Democratic party for me only one uh
institution could say that that's a high
court in Germany if they say yes they
should be forbidden okay but me or the
Press
aren't the people or the institutions to
say that so like I said a few minutes
ago it's it will be very interesting to
see how the afd and the CDU if they
compare with each other or if they go
together after the free elections we
have in East Germany that's that's that
would be very interesting well you
talked about antenna you know and I've
traveled extensively with my wife
through east east Europe Eastern Europe
in the last years multiple times many
many different countries meeting with
many many people and certainly one of
the things I saw was
that the survivors of the Soviet regime
which is all those people are much more
sensitive to the dangersous post posed
and the reality of the radical leftist
agenda that is sweeping over the Western
World in the guise of in the
hypothetical guise of the continuance of
liberalism and that's antenna and much
more likely as they did in Hungary in
consequence and to Poland in some degree
although not recently and but in Hungary
to favor modes of apprehension and
governance that keep the Communist
Spectre that Spectre of centralized
planning for example at as much Bay as
possible and so that seems to be
reflected for example in the attitude of
the East Germans that you just described
toward the globalist utopian quasi green
agenda that we've been discussing you
know my sense has been quite strong in
recent years that the Bastion of
European civilization that would be
judeo-christian civilization in Europe
is now shifted to Eastern Europe rather
than Western Europe and you know the U
with the UK playing a rather ambivalent
role in that regard because it's a
country that's very split with the
brexit people more aligned with the
Eastern Europeans and the well the labor
party which is most likely to be the
next government much more aligned with
the globalist utopians in Brussels so
Ava what's on your slate now the
protests in Germany have come to their
current conclusion and then Anthony
maybe you can tell us what's well what's
the next move that lays in front of the
protesters so Ava what are you up to
next and what are you working on and
what do you hope to have have happened
in the near future well talking about
communism and um the agenda and the
similarities with the agenda that we are
facing right now I've spoken very often
about the global war on farming right
that's the reason why I'm here right now
that's the reason why I I decided to
join the protest in the Netherlands and
speak out is I want to make people aware
of again this utopian green uh deal and
and the The Net Zero agenda and
ultimately the agenda 2030 which is a
United Nations agenda that I think is at
the core of this and that agenda to me
reeks of Communism more than anything
else but you have to really see through
the pretexts that they use so everybody
the entire world right is part of the
United Nations and the United Nations
have laid out sustainable development
goals that are ultimately at the top of
the hierarchy you know for all of these
policies that we are facing right now
that if you look at them at face value
they look very Noble you know I think
one of the first ones is to end world
hunger but then if you think about how
they would put that into practice none
of those goals can ever be achieved or
attained without the redistribution of
wealth good Goods Foods rights and so
that ultimately to me is this is neoc
communism or Neo feudalism you could
even say I guess um
packaged just a little bit nicer you
know it's like oh we are here to save
you but if you look at the reality of
things and I think that we are all
currently already experiencing that what
will happen just like with Communism in
the old days is that the ordinary people
will become poorer and more miserable
and the top layer will become even
richer and that's what we are facing
today and I will continue I I guess my
my fight and my plight for the farmers
in that sense because I truly believe
that the farmers are the one group
especially and I know that this is also
a very radical thing to say in a
European context but we in in in Europe
we don't have a second amendment I think
that the sort of the spirit of you know
wanting to protect your people against a
tyrannical government is not as embedded
in our minds as it is in let's say the
American debate right so it's really
important that people become aware of
the fact that yes we can also face
tyrannical governments and the pretty
words that they use are just pretty
words but you are going to end up poor
and miserable and so well so so the
farmers so you see and and this seems to
be a a late Motif for for your political
operating is that you seem to react as
if if it bothers the farmers and the
truckers it's probably wrong and that
seems to me to be an extremely useful
rule of thumb and it's also one you'd
think the bloody leftists would would
adhere to given their hypothetical
concern with the working class right
because you can't get more Bedrock
working class than farmers and truckers
so and that does seem to me to be a
reasonable measurement tool you know if
the policies are bothering the farmers
and making them protest something is up
because that's just not how Farmers
operate not generally and the same can
be said for truckers when they're goated
into political action something
genuinely rotten is occurring and you
know with this regard to these
sustainable development goals if you
wanted to feed the bloody poor the first
thing you would do is lower energy costs
by whatever means necessary and so if
you think you can quintuple energy costs
and feed the poor you're an idiot or
you're malevolent you know or you're
narcissistically self-serving or some
terrible combination of all of that yeah
yeah so my goal for now is to I mean I
want this agenda abolished right I want
the CH the 2030 agenda abolished I don't
want to vote for politicians who say oh
you know yeah maybe it goes a little too
fast let's push it to
2035 you know a a fast way to hell or a
long way to hell it's still a way to
hell and I just want the whole thing
gone so that's where I see my role in
this and I want to continue my political
commentary and you know in that sense I
met you guys' service because I have not
forgotten where my food comes from and I
want to be able to continue to eat
healthy foods and and live my life
freely and decide where I travel when I
travel who I meet what I eat and I don't
want the damn globalists in my business
so I know that if I don't if the farmers
fall like I said they are the group in
our society that can make a true you
know stance against the globalist they
have the manpow as we've seen to really
paralyze an entire country and and so I
hope that they do go and strike and that
they don't let themselves be intimidated
by these people who will come after you
but then will let illegal migrants flood
your and won't send them back talking
about equality before the law I mean you
know I so I that's I'm at your service I
I will support you as much as I can and
I find it extraordinar important what
you've done and very brave especially in
a nation like Germany so okay Anthony so
what's what's next for you personally
the protests this current round of
protests is folding down so what do you
go back to and then what do you see
unfolding in front of you and you're
protesting peers in the well let's say
in the next year well in the next year
we have to get rid of this government no
matter how this year we we this Germany
will cannot survive two more years of
this government and I'm mean it honestly
um like I told you earlier we we had our
finance minister he's he's from the free
Democratic party and um he tell us today
on stage because I forgot to mention
this we in Germany our Farmers we have
to um leave 4% of our land not uh seeded
so nothing is allowed to happen on this
land because our green um um Minister
wants this to happen saying in the same
sentence we have to fight because there
are so many people starving to death on
on this world we have to fight for every
handful of grain is is ridiculous it's
insane actually and he he's right in one
point every uh 3.8 seconds uh human
being dies starves to death every 13
seconds a child um under five years dies
of lack of food right and in the same
sentence we are uh over flooded with
grain from Ukraine and then we have to
we have to leave 4% of our land where we
have toay pay tax and we're not allowed
to see anything on this land it's insane
but our um Finance Minister today said
it's a point we can talk to so there's a
there's a there's a a goal maybe to
divide these two parties in this
government I mean they are divided
anyway but we can we can really um put
pressure on on uh these free Democratic
elected uh persons um people or
politicians because they are below 4% in
Germany you need 5% to make the jump
into Parliament so um all these all
these people all these politicians from
the free Democratic party obviously they
have interest in the next to be in the
next Parliament or to whatever either in
charge or not but if we if we put
pressure on that that this will make us
uh or give us a chance to divide and
maybe get rid of the government so um
this is what we're going to do we're g
to we and and and I mean that we have to
escalate another level in our protest
and um we we are capable of doing that
easily and watch them come after you for
saying this by the way like talking
about the totalitarian Spirit of the
Germans that that never left and it's
very much present in the in the current
government they they I mean I wouldn't
be surprised if they because they've
already attacked you so massively in the
media I wouldn't be surprised if this
would land us an investigation with what
they call is it the the FAS shs like the
protection of the Constitution there's a
whole agency that comes after Ordinary
People and censors them okay well but
well but but let let's um let's put all
that in context I mean one of the things
that I've been struck by in listening to
you to is that you both both implicitly
and explicitly indicated your belief
that the best possible way of sorting
all of this out is through the
Democratic means that we are already
have in place now you talked about the
necessity for protest and the right to
protest and sometimes the necessity for
civil disobedience but nowhere in any of
our discussion that did either of you
indicate that there's any Better Way
Forward than the electoral process and
the checks and balances that are
associated that with that with regard to
say the necessity for Coalition building
in both the Netherlands and in Germany
and so if they do come after you um it
isn't because you've been calling for
violent revolution and it isn't because
you're basically turned the government
on its head and establish some sort of
dictatorship radicals you know you you
you both and this is actually something
that's very positive to see is you do
believe you appear to believe that um we
can work out these problems within the
Democratic Frameworks that we've already
established and more importantly that
there is no better way that we don't of
to work them out and that seems to me to
be correct you know I mean it's
incumbent on us if we're facing
political or ideological strategies that
we don't agree with to find our way
forward in a manner that doesn't throw
the baby out with the bath water and so
well and then you see the example in the
Netherlands too of the fact that the
kinds of protests that it hasn't been as
effective in Canada by the way but
although we'll see what the long-term
consequences are in the next election
you know you you have shown in the
Netherlands the the the farmers there
certainly showed that these widescale
protests civil protests and they have
been markedly civil like they were in
Canada do c can and do have a walloping
impact on the structures of governance
and so you know maybe we need to take
something approximating a five-year view
of this you know that this is the
beginning of something new and we don't
want to get too hot and bothered about
doing anything too radically stupid and
we can let the electoral process play
itself out and and so does that seem in
keeping with what you're hoping both of
you absolutely and let me point out our
protest in the last week I mean we we
had probably 200,000 farmers and and
tractors out on on the roads and we had
so many um normal workers out the the
the truck drivers were out on the
streets and we it was so friendly and
and peaceful had no I mean in Holland we
saw some scenes where police even used
the weapon on one farmer there was
nothing like that I mean honestly not
even nobody nobody got arrested nobody
got even a ticket for a fine for
anything I mean imagine that so many
people out on the street and um in
context to that yesterday we had a
demonstration in Berlin a left wi
demonstration uh um with
21 um injured police off
office right this is this is one one
demonstration in Berlin and one week of
demonstrations all over Germany with
hundreds of thousand people out not even
a ticket not even a fine nothing so
nobody can tell us we are not peaceful
and and like I said I was a police
officer I know what um some
demonstrations can turn out to be and
still be and still be in legal rights
and and we will carry on peace friendly
but we need to um increase the power and
like if I said we have the power we can
shut down the country for good and we
will do if
necessary so so that's also a very
optimistic set of observations because
you know not only did you point out that
the people who were protesting did so
like the Canadian truckers did with
extremely peace peaceably in fact the
crime rate in Ottawa fell during the
trucker Convoy but also the authorities
in Germany as you pointed out responded
in kind right and that there wasn't
provocation and there wasn't violence
and so that's all the more reason why we
can be optimistic that these difficult
discussions that we're having about how
we're going to conduct ourselves into
the future can be done within the
confines of of the legal Frameworks and
the Electoral Frameworks that are
already established and with hopefully a
certain degree of goodwi and intelligent
foresight on all sides so well good all
right well look you two thank you very
much for agreeing to talk to me today
well we'll keep in touch all three of us
with any degree of luck and because I
definitely want to watch as this unfolds
I certainly share your uh sense Eva that
if it's upsetting the farmers and the
truckers then something serious has gone
astray and that everyone should be
attending to to that's particularly true
for farmers in places like the
Netherlands and Germany who are as
Anthony pointed out well
generally extraordinarily competent
people in a very very difficult
Enterprise with their ears to the ground
and their eyes open and also very
unlikely to act politically unless
necessity has driven to them them to
that extreme and for everybody watching
and listening on the on YouTube your
time and attention is much appreciated
you want to be um alert to the goings on
in Europe on the populist Uprising front
in Spain in Poland in Germany in the
Netherlands because this is a harbinger
of things to come um all right till we
talk again byebye by byebye thank
[Music]
you